ouais
ma
un nombre des ormeaux séculaire qui
abritait les amours de joséphine de
beauharnais de bonaparte une maison bien
vivante s'est ouverte pour vous nous y
avons rencontré une famille paisible et
heureuse celle de salvatore adamo auteur
compositeur à succès
alors adamo aujourd'hui nous avons
réussi à percer le mystère de votre vie
privée c'est à dire de votre vie de pays
dans campagne a gentleman farmer ou là
pas vraiment parce que malheureusement
cette maison vous voyez je suis très
rarement et c1 mais grand regret si je
ne peux pas en profiter vraiment et les
fleurs elle pousse que je suis pas là
les animaux heureusement j'ai pris le
temps de les connaître à l'eau malgré
l'absence de son président elle et quand
je reviens ils me font la fête commence
est-ce qu'il vous manque sans ça quand
vous êtes en tournée quand vous êtes en
déplacement au camp je suis très loin
quand je suis quand je reste longtemps
sans revenir oui parce que quand je vais
dans les pays comme comme le japon
disons que les chiens sont prêts à la
voix bombe et j'en ressens l'absence est
souvent il ya des petits rappels à
gauche à droite je vois un chien qui me
rappelle les miens et tout de suite je
fais le rapprochement vise les jeunes
est ce que vous avez eu aussi au temps
des moteurs de voûte en tient un papa
autant à la fois mais j'ai toujours eu
un compagnon que ce soit un chat ou un
chien je suis premier animal que j'avais
eue c'était un berger allemand comme mon
père avait recueilli qu'on avait appelé
15 ans puis avait rita puis à chaque
brique du staff j'ai tout payé une
tortue on avait appelé 2010 mais
pourquoi donc aussi longtemps où vous
puissiez vous en souvenir les animaux
toujours cette partie de votre oeil
c'est une présence rassurante pour nous
donner nous l'origine et le nom de la
race de vos deux gros chiens
ce sont deux leonberg leonberg est une
ville
des souabes près de stuttgart allemagne
et je crois que leurs origines remontent
à deux cents ans
voilà on le croisait internautes et un
berger allemand
et voilà ce que ça donne c'est quoi la
terreur comme race oui c'est assez l'âme
je sais qu'en france il y a il ya un
élevage lyon vers louis puisqu'on est
venu lui demander barnabé pour perpétuer
la race de nous demander une forme de
démence beaucoup il mange son petit kg
driss un petit kilo de viande plus un
petit steak dans l'assiette du voisin
les gâteaux tout tout tout la caisse de
gâteau il est trés voleurs quand on
côtoie est bizarre d'habitude il rappelé
non mais je ne lance pas il saute quand
même qu'avant avec
la place que vous réservé aux animaux
dans votre vie de tous les jours disons
que ce sont des compagnons ils ne nous
contrediront jamais ils sont toujours à
votre avis de toute façon que vous soyez
gay qui sont gays avec vous que vous
savez triste mois ils seront à vos pieds
et son triste aussi crois qu'il ya c'est
un complément parfait manette n'y avait
aucun encore on le verra tout à l'heure
ça valait rien confiait philippe nauche
a brillé mais de quoi nous a offert
aussi mettre les mains là mais ils sont
tous les deux de la même rage parce que
dans ma b qui s'ennuyait tout seul tout
humaine
pour lui tenir compagnie pour moi c'est
à dire que armand c'est un chien mais ça
me pose c'est la magie de l'enfance
armand se transforme tour à tour en lion
en éléphant et un jour j'ai surpris en
tenir
essayant de le dresser dû montrer
comment on pouvait sauter si un tabouret
comme les lions il avait pris un petit
sursaut il voulu se passer au travers
j'ai un mot serment je crois qu'il a
dressée anthony et moi ça m'a donné
l'occasion d'être une chanson que
j'avais intitulé les cirques d'anthony
vous preniez un jour dans nos vies sur
la serre martière safari son chantier et
j'ai vu ces chiens abandonnés ce prix il
était petit il était tout seul tout et
ça vous être un chien ferme où il avait
aidé à voir deux ou trois mois et tu as
eu envie de le recueillir un jeune homme
et de futile aime beaucoup et oui dans
la malle
- de ma chambre noire toujours
à
c'est moi qui les offrent du japon je
les appelais en lui disant on veut
m'offrir un chien qu'est-ce que j'en
fais non non non surtout pas ce soit
cinq petits revient quand même avec et
bienvenue la nave combien d'années parce
qu'on ne sait plus là on en a quatre
on en a eu plus oui je vais faire un
petit caniche j'avais ramené de suisse
son pedigree c'était caprices de saint
sulpice excusez moi du peu
ils ont l'air aux baptisés gudule de
sainte ursule alors cet homme est
requise en occupe maintenant c'est ma
mère la mère d'accueil les déchets et
barnabé qu'on a surnommé dans un bus ont
renoncé baryton le schlossberg milanello
dont vous pourriez vivre son chien non
vraiment pas on a vécu dans un petit
appartement avant d'habiter ici son
chien sans chat etc la ville en effet
comme chien c'est une présence et c'est
une infection c'est une tendresse et
messieurs vous avez marqué sont pas du
tout dressé ils sont libres et font ce
qu'ils veulent on les appelle ils
viennent ou reviennent pas suivant les
têtes qu'on a
et puis c'est mieux comme ça à
l'intérieur vous intéresser le chien on
s'amuse éric on est une personne c'est
selon car en maîtrise c'est moi ce sont
tes conseils dans reims il presque aussi
comme si c'étaient mes camarades d'école
à
maman
non
où